[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look of course at what
is on the front pages
time to see what is making the headlines
with pippa crewe the political editor of
the daily mirror and the political
editor of the sun harry cole both of us
from with us from now until just before
midnight and welcome to both of you so
to the front pages then let us start
with the i which leads with the letter
from bishops condemning tomorrow's
flight to rwanda carrying channel
migrants and saying it shames the uk
the metro leading with that story too
and the court rejection of an injunction
to stop the flight with the headline
clear for takeoff
threats from the eu to take legal action
over the government's plans to rewrite
parts of the northern ireland
post-brexit trade protocol make the
front page of the financial times that
story also the lead for the guardian eu
to fight the uk
in court it says there the times also
making it the front page eu pledges
legal action over brexit violation
well despite the cost of living crisis
the telegraph reports that boss johnson
is ruling out tax cuts until the rate of
inflation has eased pippa's paper the
mirror says prince william threatened to
pull out of a royal engagement today if
prince andrew was allowed to take part
and always up for a weather story the
star
goes with the looming heat wave and the
headline hell's bells
it's not gonna be that hot for very long
is it anyway a reminder that by scanning
the qr code you'll see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch the programme so let's
uh go to peppa carrera political editor
of the daily mirror then and the
political editor of the sun harry cole
lovely to see both of you um so harry
let's start with the ft goodness me here
we go again talking about northern
ireland and and its protocol
yeah we've sort of been talking about
this bill coming for so long but now
it's landed actually um it's a bit of a
damp squib i'm gonna say actually i was
expecting this to
land with a bit more of a thud uh both
here uh both in brussels both in dublin
they've been sort of their dire sort of
warnings for for months on end actually
this will trigger an all-out trade war
it will plunge relations with brussels
into the into the deep freeze
and um and all sorts of retaliation
would be coming now actually brussels
response tonight seems to be well we'll
probably consider maybe de-icing some of
the legal action we were perhaps
considering
taking but actually all those very
bellicose threats of cutting off brexit
britain and slapping tariffs on trade
have actually been quite muted and i
think the the situation in ukraine
certainly has had an effect on the fact
that brexit just isn't on the in the top
of anyone's entry
right now it's not at the top of
anyone's agenda and actually it cost a
living crisis as well britain said look
we're going to do this because we don't
think the the protocol is working for us
but we're not gonna we're not gonna put
any tariffs if you slap tariffs on us
we're not gonna stop any towers on news
so goods coming to the uk would actually
be the same price for uk consumers
whereas brussels threw up the trade
barriers actually goods that go from
england and scotland and
wales and the united kingdom sorry um
into the european union would be hit by
higher prices so actually it first bill
if there's ever time to have this row
now might just be it
well you say that but um ireland's simon
covney for example uh one of those
highly critical suggesting it was a new
low saying publishing legislation that
would breach the uk's commitment under
international law the brexit withdrawal
agreement the northern ireland protest
he always says that it's deeply damaging
but it doesn't mean it doesn't happen
he's been saying that for two years it
was not exactly i'd say if it was a bit
more than simon copely saying it i think
it would be a dramatic uh automatic
moment but simon covey has been whining
for three years well mara shefkovic also
said it um and uh anthony blinken yet
another person that liz trust spoke to
uh suggested they really need to go back
to the drawboard and talk to the
european union about this you know who
is being inflexible here certainly the
accusation from the uk government is
that the european union is being
inflexible but the eu's suggesting that
liz trust hasn't properly engaged since
february so you know how much of this is
politics how much is reality that this
is simply not working for northern
ireland this protocol pippa
i think there's a lot of politics in
here clearly and i think harry is right
in saying that brexit isn't the top of
anyone's entry when there's so much else
going on but i don't think anybody was
seriously expecting the day that this
legislation was published the european
union's turn around and slapped tariffs
on on goods uh the prospect of a trade
war was some way down the line let's not
forget that this has to make its way
through parliament first and while i
think despite the fuse of
tories that it it's all everyone expects
it to make it through the house of
commons it's likely to run into some
trouble in the house of lords however
uh there'll be questions about why um
their government views this they've used
this principle of doctrine of necessity
seeing the protocols causing peril to
society and politics in northern ireland
because of the threat to good variety
agreement i expect that will be
challenged quite robustly in the house
of lords to be asking why didn't they
use the left in
article 16 which is
a lesser threshold um so i don't think
anybody expects this to make it through
parliament anytime soon in fact it could
take many many months or even up to a
year so it doesn't surprise me at all
that brussels is is holding fire on uh
on uh it's its plans sesekovich made
quite clear today that he doesn't intend
to renegotiate the protocol despite the
sort of the suggestions that be flexible
on some areas of um
of uh of goods this is the good channels
i think there's room for some movement
there um but as ever with this uh the
biggest the biggest block to it is not
what's actually happening in northern
ireland but it's the
message that brussels is worried that it
would send out if they did uh agree to
rip up parts of the brexit deal to other
countries which might be eyeing very
closely what was happening with britain
and brexit and potentially you know
looking at some of the eastern european
countries notably hungary um where there
is sort of a groundswell of opinion
against the eu and clearly brussels
doesn't want any other countries to
leave to leave the block so you know
it's not just about the politics on the
ground it's also the bigger picture as
well
more on that or shall i move on to
rwanda harry what do you reckon
let's do this for a little bit longer
everybody says that there are problems
with the protocol
um be that the republicans be that the
uh the dup be that the tories even labor
except that there are issues with
protocol and how and how the protocol
has been implemented labor um sorry the
eu have
um taken a very sort of um very very
very strict approach uh almost
ridiculously strict approach to
implementing the protocol and there is a
slight argument though that they've
slightly overplayed their hand in the
fact that sort of almost all of the sort
of vast majority of all checks coming
into the single market is done in
northern ireland despite it being a tiny
fraction of goods coming into it so i do
think there is an element of
inflexibility on these parts but
cescovich can say we're not negotiating
that's not because he doesn't want to
it's because he hasn't got his mandate
we talk about the fact there's no the eu
is a sacred rules-based order and they
have to you know sort of keep their
rules all the time in order to you know
set an example to other states as pippa
made uh said there but actually they do
fold all the time they do move they
suddenly you know it's a rules-based
order until they bend the rules so i do
think that actually it will take a
little while to get this through
parliament but it is clearly a
negotiation tactic these talks have been
going on for 18 months with no sign of
no sign of breaking everyone's saying oh
get back back get back around the table
there's no point in getting back around
the table if there's no if there's no
movement this is clearly a negotiating
tactic to show that you're willing to
use a big stick and hopefully that big
stick can loosen up what is audience
down there people was actually nodding
in agreement with you there so that
might be an indicator that i can now i
don't know
because many of the newspapers
i know i don't know i'm giving you far
too much control i think tonight well
there we are
um so let's move on because many of the
newspapers are leading on rwanda uh this
first flight due to set off on tuesday
certainly one of the charities care for
calais said the numbers have been
diminishing who would you on that plane
because of individual legal challenges
suggesting it was now seven
who were due to take that place we'll
see what happens um overnight and first
thing tomorrow morning on that one um
but uh certainly the the blanket
uh
applications to both the high court and
the appeal court have failed though
pippa
yes um now this doesn't mean that the
the
overall policy is lawful that was going
to be tested in a more substantial
case uh later this month i think it is
but it does mean that the appeal court
held up the ruling on friday which is
that the flight can take off so the
first of all of this though is that the
flight may may well end up taking off
empty harry as i'm sure been talking to
him office sources today as i have um
who's suggesting that the number is down
to about 11 now or certainly was a
couple of hours ago
and we could as you rightly say
10 now seven seven seven
i think it's seven seven right yeah
so presumably by about three in the
morning they'll be down to um we're down
to zero um
you know
again once again there's the sort of the
reality of what's happening on the
ground and there's and there's sort of
the backdrop of the politics of it and
the reality is that the government wants
to
do several things it wants to prevent uh
illegal immigrants uh from settling in
the uk it wants to deter people from
making those really dangerous crossings
across the channel and those small boats
and it wants to tackle those criminal
gangs
who run human trafficking or human
trafficking operations the you know i
don't think there's anybody that uh
thinks that it's right to try and
preserve life uh indeed the opposite
people do the vast majority of people
everybody wants to make sure that those
small boats don't end up
resulting in those crossings don't end
up people putting their lives in peril
but the questions remain over whether
this is the right way to do it this is
an expensive policy this is one which
we're not sure is actually going to work
the government has said that it's going
to do big advertising blitz to sort of
warn all those people in the camps in
cali that if they come over they're
likely to be shipped out to um
to rwanda but if you know the first
fighters endings to go by will they
believe it um and uh there's also you
know there's also the case that many
many the vast majority of people that
arrive here on these shores either um in
their initial application or their first
appeal end up being granted asylum
status so you know is this problem
actually as big as we think it is or is
it about the the political messaging it
sends out about protecting borders and
looking tough on immigration that this
particular government is very keen
to promote because it chimes well with
this with its core vote particularly
some of those that voted for the first
time in 2019 now it's hard
not to escape the feeling that it's a
little bit more about politics sometimes
with this than it is about the actual
reality on the ground there are other
ways that you could prevent crossings
not least setting up safe routes from
some of those countries that i think
it's syria um
syria iraq and iran uh with the names
that the countries of the the
individuals who won that first flight
would do to be on that first flight i
should say why not have safe routes
directly from those countries we don't
currently have any at the moment or why
not have processing centres in france
why not have a better relationship work
hard having a better relationship with
the french which frankly is a real low
point so that they agree to to patrol
the beaches more to prevent
we're paying them to patrol the beaches
we're already paying the french to
patrol the beaches and they're not doing
anything
enough obviously not well enough
well so you think just keep throwing
money at the french until they say yeah
all right we'll stop it no i don't i
think have a good relationship a better
relationship with french which frankly
at the moment is pretty dire and trust
is on both sides is very very low and
cut try and come up with a solution
whether it's processing centers in
france i appreciate that there are
concerns about them being sort of a
magnet for more people coming but there
are ways to there are ways
the great complaint about this and we
and we see the eye picking up on this
letter written by bishops in the times
uh we've got the letter from the times
as well um which is the the calling this
rwanda policy immoral
and it shames the uk that's the eyes
coverage of that uh letter in the times
on tuesday but the idea that there is no
safe passage for people from those
countries that they're pippa listed has
been the complaint about this harry why
not have some route that people can get
here properly then
firstly there are lots of safe routes to
come to this country and people that are
taking the smuggler's route are skipping
those cues
well as we go through the 300 000 people
that we've invited from hong kong who've
agreed to come to this country 125 000
people from ukraine
there are ways there are ways to apply
for asylum in this country without going
into the hands of the people's mothers
the other problem is with your safe and
legal roots which is not something i
disagree with per se other than to say
that if you do create those safe and
legal routes
you have to put a cap on that unless
you're saying safe and legal routes for
anyone that wants to come to this
country you don't have to put a crap in
there and the problem is if you put a
cap on it you're still going to have
people who don't qualify or want to skip
that queue who will continue to come
without a deterrent effect this is where
i have some sympathy for the for
for the home office in the fact is
in order to create a deterrent you've
got to be prepared to use some slightly
eccentric ways of doing this whether or
not it works or not and whether or not
it's particularly comfortable with
people or not for want of a better idea
we're all is let's hear them the public
are crying out for this problem to be
fixed i'm only hearing one solution so
far we've got independence referendums
and tax cuts to pack in still uh so do
stay tuned lots more coming up including
that's throwing the telegraph no tax
cuts before inflation calls off of the
latest on that just back
[Music]
well welcome out you're watching the
press preview we are joined once again
by pipa creera the political editor of
the daily mirror and the political
editor of the sun harry cole pippa let's
head to the delhi telegraph shall we
the idea of tax cuts to come there's
certainly been that mood music from many
conservatives that they want to see a
return to them being described as a tax
cutting party but it looks like it won't
happen imminently
yeah and actually this is i mean it's a
bit of an odd front page really because
this is something that prime minister
and um
all the treasury number 10 have been
saying for a couple of weeks now that
there's absolutely no plans and dining
streets as well there's no plans
to cut taxes for households until
inflation is under control um the plans
for business taxes later this year uh
being cut but all the suggestions of the
last couple of weeks have been you know
pushed back at those calls
from tory mps and others who have asked
for
tax cuts sooner as a way in their view
of addressing the cost of living crisis
uh we're told that the chancellor and
the prime minister are both as one on
this um that was the one sort of
development is that the prime minister
was asked about this on on the radio
this morning um and said that he of
course understands need to bear down on
taxation and certainly will but we've
got an inflationary spike that we've got
to get through right now looking after
people as we do that to go through that
that's what we're going to do so
concentrating on getting through the
initial cost of living crisis obviously
the concern in the treasury is that
cutting taxes would would help um would
help push up inflation further despite
suggestions from the oecd and others
last week that that wasn't wasn't the
case but they they've obviously taken
the decision okay and harry very quickly
on that because i've suddenly raised the
next stories on scottish independence
which would make sense if pooper talked
about really i wouldn't know where they
were so just very quickly on on the idea
of tax cuts just very quickly
yeah look i think there's definitely
business tax cuts and then tax cuts for
people who want to invest you know
companies to invest in the in the autumn
i do wonder whether the sort of
inevitability of tax cuts coming means
that they're slightly playing it down
now so it can be a big surprise a big
political win when they do come rather
than just being seen as an inability
yeah that would make sense and a quick
30 seconds on um the prospect of
scottish independence a fresh campaign
being launched by nicola sturgeon pippa
well stefan's slightly running her out
of road on this she has to keep throwing
red meat at her party and the and sort
of the pro-independence movement that
are pushing for another independence
referendum but at the same time she's a
cautious person and won't want to do it
until she knows she can win so the
latest the latest uh
step foot down the road is a whole
series of papers tomorrow on how
scotland can be wealthy happier and
fairer further down the line on things
like currency and tax and spend which i
guess she's hoping will uh convince uh
more people that she is at least
thinking about a
vote she said there'll be another vote
before the end of next year of course
there's absolutely no sign of the
british government giving her their
blessing their consent for that which
means it would have been a legal one uh
wildcat one rather which she said she
doesn't want to do
it's just about
a line sorry to interrupt you pippa
clearer harry cole thank you very much
indeed thank you